didn't know too much about the real
problems in the country I'd say that I
mean there are problems of race that we
hardly knew existed in San Francisco but
they were right in front of us and
gradually got to see what they were I
can remember my mother telling me one
day she had a friend who was black and
they wanted to go to a restaurant for
lunch and they were going to go to the
st. Francis hotel and they were
discussing whether they could and that
was San Francisco that wasn't the south
there is not a magic answer you know I'm
probably since I recently wrote a
dissent in the in the in a case
involving the use of race conscious
criteria in schools that is whether the
City of Seattle could use a as one
criteria among several they allowed high
school students freedom to choose
whatever school they wanted they listed
preferences but they said that no school
will be more than eighty-five percent
white basically that was their criterion
and the question was could they actually
overtly in that way use a racial
criteria and the court 524 decided that
they could not they could not I
descended I thought of course they can
we're consequences relevant there they
certainly were to me as I said if you
interpret the Equal Protection Clause 2
into forbid this how are people supposed
to deal with problems of race and
poverty in the inner cities of America
and I see the Constitution as a very
workable document I think Madison's
genius was to say we're going to get
these values which stay the same and
we're going to embody them in words that
allow their application over the course
of the next four or five hundred years
and if know if not longer and to do that
you have to refer back to how do these
values apply today what's the value of
the Equal Protection Clause trying to
bring us together trying to create one
nation trying to create race
that were separate indeed one held in
slavery like a caste system and try to
create one country out of this diversity
and it's a miracle but we've been able
to do that to a degree there's still
plenty of problems and for me to think
of that clause being posed as an
obstacle to such an effort well I just
think that that was wrong and I
expressed my views very concisely in
about 77 pages I'm basically optimistic
even with the thing I was most
pessimistic about to go back to a rather
specific case I would I was most
pessimistic about the court's decision
in the Seattle case involving the use of
race conscious criteria well I think
about that seriously I was in the
dissent I think it's a bad decision
that's what I wrote of the the it
impedes the ability of communities to
take people who are isolated in the
center of the city very poor a family
background could be terrible and lacking
opportunity and try to work out the
problems in the in the community context
so I think this is a bad decision it's a
throwback but it's only a throwback you
see because really ultimately I am an
optimist and ultimately I do think that
people overcome even this kind of a
barrier and people figure out how to
solve these problems not perfectly but
will do it the country itself is
becoming much more of a diverse country
and yet we can cooperate we cooperate we
know how to do it that's really I think
our our great if there's an American
contribution I think it's in that
respect the respect of being open and
coming into a problem and not being
prejudiced about it and trying to look
for whatever solution arises out of the
problem it's a pragmatic attitude it's
an attitude that is not a respecter of
persons it's a respecter of problems and
if we don't just take what people say as
information
Oh